Bruce Jenner is is is such a unique
circumstance and situation in his coming
out is is a high point in the
transgender movement curling because
that have somebody that high-profile be
willing to to share in that way and
transgender is almost the the last of
the LGBTQ spectrum that people don't
understand you know if you're you know a
Yankees fan and you have your yankees
jersey the the thought of having to wear
it being socially acceptable that the
only thing you could wear was a red sox
jersey it would just make your skin
crawl and then to think about feeling
like that every single day or if you are
secure in your gender identity imagine
if you had the opposite genitalia and
what that would feel like I mean to me
there are these when it becomes personal
and we go to these feelings of what does
your body do when you imagine these
things then I think we can we can begin
to relate on on another level so I think
for for Bruce to make that decision and
do that and do it so publicly and and
take the questions and like like we said
be kind of the 101 version of that it
gives us all a point of reference you
you love them or you have an opinion
about them or you don't but but you
doesn't change because these transgender
you